c'était un vieux rêve de la gauche l'une
des promesses phares de françois
mitterrand candidat ps à la
présidentielle de 1981 cela fait bien
quinze que la gauche et donc les
socialistes proposent l'abaissement de
la retraite à l'âge de 60 ans partir à
la retraite à 60 ans au lieu de 65 ans
auparavant et sous réserve d'avoir
cotisé 37 ans et demi pour les salariés
du public et du privé françois
mitterrand une fois élu à l'elysée tient
son engagement le 25 mars 1982 la loi
est adopté par ordonnance dès cette
ordonnance adoptée hier en conseil des
ministres la plus remarquée a sans
conteste été celle prévoyant la retraite
à 60 ans très vite plusieurs questions
se posent comment mettre en place cette
mesure qui va payer
du côté des syndicats on s'interroge
cela nous conduit à augmenter la
cotisation de 25% même crainte chez le
syndicat patronal le cnpf l'ancêtre du
medef dans ce pas non plus qui va payer
le 8 février 1983 après des mois de
négociations un accord est signé entre
les syndicats et le gouvernement ce sera
une grande date dans notre histoire
sociale la loi entre vigueur le 1er
avril 1983 la retraite à 60 ans à taux
plein c'est ok mais huit ans plus tard
en 1991 elle est remise en question avec
la sortie du livre blanc sur les
retraites
ouvrage est préfacé par le premier
ministre de l'époque michel rocard parmi
les pistes de réforme l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation on ne prévoit pas
de toucher aux droits actuels des
retraités et on conserve le principe de
la retraite à 60 ans mais on envisage de
porter progressivement la durée de
versement des cotisations de 37 ans et
demi actuellement à 41 ou 42 ans la
durée de cotisation est allongé en 1993
mais uniquement pour le secteur privé
l'annoncé faite par edouard balladur
premier ministre de droite lors de la
deuxième cohabitation sous françois
mitterrand à terme il faudra en arriver
à passer de 37 années et demie à 40
années de cotisation la réforme balladur
est adoptée le 22 juillet 1993 dix ans
plus tard en 2003 la durée de cotisation
du public est alignée sur celle du privé
c'est la réforme fillon depuis 2010
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite est
fixé à 62 ans le président emmanuel
macron veut la longère 65 ans
[Musique]